[Music]  ed Westwick claims he's never met the  woman accusing him of sexual assault  here's what we know so far  on Monday actress Christina Cohen penned  a lengthy Facebook post alleging that  she was sexually assaulted by the Gossip  Girl star during a visit to his  residence three years ago on Tuesday  Westwick took to social media to  vehemently deny Cohen's accusation  writing I do not know this woman I have  never forced myself in any manner on any  woman I certainly have never committed  rape in her post Cohen claims that  Westwick suggested she take a nap in his  guest room where she eventually fell  asleep adding I was woken up abruptly by  Ed on top of me Cohen claims to have  fought him off as hard as I could but  says Westwick was strong and quote held  me down and raped me as for why Cohen  didn't report the alleged incident when  it happened she claims her boyfriend  placed blame on her and told her that  westweek would destroy her acting career  [Music]  you